hi there Steve Kaufman here I got my
London School of Economics t-shirt on I
never went there but my son did today
I'm gonna talk about self control and
language learning I was at golfing today
the weather here in Vancouver is
phenomenal it's I don't know how hot
it's gonna be today it was 28 30 degrees
centigrade and we were talking with we
were playing with this other couple and
we were talking about things that we can
control and things that we can't control
it's very difficult to control your
swing in golf however much you practice
it's very difficult you never quite know
what's gonna what's gonna happen when
you swing the ball or swing the club at
the ball and there's lots of things we
can't control we can't control the
weather we can't necessarily control
what's gonna happen you know politically
economically all these different things
we can't control we worry about we
follow in the news we think of what we
think our solutions or whatever it might
be we can't really control them and it's
always useful to focus on things that
you can control because you'll be
happier if you focus on things you can't
control that are out of your control
you can be disappointed then there's
nothing you can do about it language
learning is something that you can
control and if we get back to the three
sort of basic keys that I always refer
to your attitude towards the language
the time you spend on the language and
your ability to notice what's happening
in the language those are things that
are within your control so if you say I
don't like the language study another
language or get into it a bit and you'll
start to like it so many things that
relate to our attitude towards the task
of language learning or the language
we're learning are things that are
within our control we have to try to
become positive to be confident
to persuade ourselves that it's
worthwhile doing this thing all of those
kinds and and you know to like it
and all of those kinds of things that we
can influence and I have referred in the
past to this book by a professor of
psychology I bleep called Jeffery
Schwartz who spoke about the mind and
the brain and how he was able to help
people who had obsessive-compulsive
disorder and rather than using drugs he
was able to persuade them that they
could actually control the workings of
their mind and you can influence
yourself to like the language influenced
yourself to feel confident to accept you
know whatever you have achieved and to
feel good about it rather than spending
your time feeling unhappy about what
you're not able to achieve so you can
control your attitude
I believe you can control your attitude
towards the language you can control the
time you spend with the language you
have to prioritize and you have other
things you have to do work family
whatever but if it's something that's
important to you you can find the time
so you can control the time you spend on
the language and when it comes to
noticing the language here again if you
are determined to notice you're gonna
pay attention gonna pay attention to the
pronunciation you're gonna pay attention
to the structures and if you pay
attention and you notice the language
here and there and somewhere else
eventually you're going to absorb it so
you can control it now people are gonna
say yes but I have no talent for
language blah blah blah these are the
kinds of things that you shouldn't say
to yourself because whatever your talent
level is for learning languages the
better your attitude the more positive
you are the better you like the language
the better you the more confident you
feel the better you're gonna do whatever
your talent level is and I have said
before I don't think talent is the big
factor attitude is much more important
than talent so
if you have the determination that you
want to succeed that determination will
ensure that you maintain a positive
attitude spend the necessary time and
focus on noticing what's happening in
the language and these are things that
we can control how wonderful if you're a
boat or you can't control the weather if
I'm a golfer I can't control and I try
you know I can't hit that straight you
know drive or or whatever iron shot when
I want to but language learning is
something that we can actually control
we can control our attitude towards it
the time we spend on it and our
attentiveness to what's happening in the
language so I think that's an important
point and you know when I look at the
world we live in today I mean how many
millions or billions of dollars are
spent on golf or bogey or you know
computer games or all of this kind of
thing language learning is you know it
should be however much money is spent on
it should be ten times as much because
it gives you so much my wife and I are
gonna travel to France in September we
can both speak French we'll have a
wonderful time
how much nicer time than if we couldn't
speak French there's so many advantages
that come from learning languages and
it's an activity where you can control
the outcome so learn languages and with
that